hello and welcome to Playstation
grenades are you playing warframe yet
you should be the free-to-play behemoth
has steadily improved since 2013 but
over the last 12 months it has soared to
new heights
each year the awesome community meet up
at 10 o Con and receive a loose roadmap
for the next 12 months 10 o con 2018 was
no exception and it revealed so much
content let's quickly go through 15 new
things that are coming to our frame and
yes they are free let's start with the
really huge stuff which most probably is
the longest time away warframe Rail Jack
this new game-mode puts you on board
this hulking ship called a rail jack to
navigate around the solar system and
take down enemy command ships this is
going to be a multiplayer cooperative
experience so when this hits the fan
make sure you have people to rely on the
fire fight looks like a scene from Star
Wars but that's only the starting point
in the live demo we've seen the enemy
can board our ship form our traditional
warframe action
this is a two-way dog though if you're
one of those people who enjoy using the
archwing simply exit the rail jack it's
even possible to invade the enemy's
battleship all the best parts of
warframe can be found in rail Jack in a
hugely dynamic way with new elements -
for example it's possible to hack
turrets from our own vessel in order to
help our teammate on the opposition ship
Rebecca's gotta go attack the Gulf to
disable it for first maybe use a little
turret help that's ten Oh on the enemy
ship isn't there just to cause havoc
they're looking for the ship's core
which is the key to winning this space
battle taking out the supporting pillars
will allow the car to be scanned and
back on our ship the railgun our trans
beam if you prefer can blow the enemy
out of existence
[Music]
that looks so damn satisfying did you
ever try the plains of eidolon expansion
I thought the community loved it it was
essentially a work in progress a
demonstration for future content
essentially it was a test to see if open
world would fit into a game like
warframe those small steps forward have
been followed up by the developers
Digital Extremes
and that progression has led to warframe
Fortuna
goddamnit that song sticks in your head
Fortuna is set on Venus and consists of
an open world populated by copper slaves
known as the Solaris who have a chain
gang mentality like a brotherhood or
sisterhood gotta be politically correct
these days these guys have a desire to
replace parts of their Anatomy with
technology which leads to some unique
character designs the open world itself
will make the plains of Eidolon look
tiny
and like POA bounties and rewards are
the principal mechanic to this area
fortuna introduces kitt guns an
extension to the modular weapon system
found in past updates kit guns are
created from three different components
that can be mixed and matched allowing
players to create different combinations
with different stats and abilities that
they desire we can determine if the kit
gun is a primary or secondary weapon and
the best thing of all we can rename our
weapons to whatever we like my first
weapon shall be named but stallion
speaking over the modular system Fortuna
introduces a great new way to create a
mower companion using the same
principles as before different
components dictate different attributes
and the look of your companion the devs
couldn't resist slapping a hat and a
bowtie on theirs
while Juna gives us a whole new gameplay
system centered around locating rescuing
and capturing animals using their
footsteps in the snow or the occasional
pile of which of course you need to
shoot you know just to check the physics
engine we'll be tracking down many
species using this echo lure and
tranquilizers we can mimic the animals
calls and then move in before they
become spooked essentially we're hunting
without killing doors okay here's a
brilliant addition the Bondi K Drive
which from here on out I'll be calling
the freaking hoverboard
the Back to the Future music is already
floating in my head this is here to help
us travel far distances quickly in open
world gaming board and can't set in from
traveling miles which breaks up the flow
of the game the hoverboard here in
Fortuna should prevent that of course a
new location comes new enemy types and
bosses these crab-like runts can have
their heads popped and legs can be
destroyed too but it's their bigger
brothers that will take us time to beat
in the demo the devs didn't want to show
us how to beat this mini boss but made
reference to those enemies on Venus
which will have their own mechanics to
beat just like the eidelons in p OE
other things that weren't shown in the
presentation include hidden caves to
uncover mechanical fish to locate lair
ops to find but Digital Extremes wants
us to experience those for ourselves
stating but we want you to discover and
explore this vast alien hostile world
yourself and we really hope you enjoy
what the team has brought for you
although those expansions make up the
wow factor of 10 or con 2018 there's a
boatload truckload lorry load of other
content coming soon let's fly through
them in ultra QuickTime a new warframe
is currently in development
this is Garuda this warframe will be
based around the theme of gah
new deluxe warframe skins are on the way
many of which are still works in
progress but include limbo deluxe
titania deluxe Nezzer deluxe
Vauban deluxe nixed Alok Schneider still
looks and ridiculous a hammer options
two new weapons are on the way which
include this corpus shotgun and revolver
a glaive 1000 jewel axes revenant
warframe shotgun there's a frying gram
soul in there as well and loads more to
look forward to over the summer NYX
prime and Rhino prime will be unbolted
allowing us time once again to get our
hands on them even though my primary
focus is PlayStation we have to show
warframe on Nintendo switch warframe on
the go I may have to buy a switch as
Sony won't make me a Vita - we're still
waiting to know if account sharing will
be possible in the past only small areas
of migration were possible between
PlayStation and PC and after the
fortnight debacle
it probably won't be a thing but we can
hope if you have Amazon Prime or twitch
Prime there's free
to be downloaded rights now between July
16th and August 12th we can pick up this
exclusive skin and the reusable color
palette for free the last thing is a
little bit spoilery so I'm going to rush
it so I don't spoil it for myself
another cinematic quest is coming soon
the new war it will follow on from the
sacrifice quest which was released very
recently so I don't want to see any more
so take it down now now take it away ok
so there we have it 15 new things coming
to warframe over the next 12 months
Digital Extremes please take about this
is truly impressive work I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade and I think it's
finally time I played the second dream
I'll see you next time
[Music]